[Music]
I've been dying to say this for weeks
Shante you stay condragulations were in
order for RuPaul Friday as he was
honored with a star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame I wish for each and every
person within the sound of my voice that
your dreams can come true as mine have
this is absolutely the most important
moment in my professional career thank
you so much
condragulations your husband came out
Jane was here really cool to see now
when you won the Emmy you told me that
meant more for the show for the network
yeah what does this star right here mean
to you this star on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame is everything to me this is this
was a goal of mine from childhood
literally from the time I first visited
Hollywood Boulevard tell today this was
the dream and to finally achieve it it
means the world to me I have been doing
this for 36 years successfully for 34 25
years and this is the real sign of
success
the champion of All Stars 3 is
[Music]
Trixie Mattel
all search three wrapped up last night
fans have had a mixed reaction what's
your message to those ones that are
upset out there well you know we do a
really fabulous show that is there to
entertain everyone you know all stars is
filled with Queens who everyone loves
and everyone has their favorites but the
truth is they're all winners you know
they're all the girls are winners I'm
really happy for Trixie though if you
can't love yourself how in the hell you
gonna love somebody else can I get an
amen up in here all right
thank you everybody thank you
[Music]
[Applause]